I deal with people who haven't even got
to the point where they're worrying
about whether other people are
manipulating them or trying to influence
other people they're working on their
own self-sabotaging behaviors so it's
about understanding your own you know
bringing from non-conscious to conscious
to things that you do that are barriers
to your success in in life and work
um and it's connected to what you said
Nick about you know do we compete or do
we collaborate
didn't we cooperate to compete didn't we
collaborate with large numbers of other
humans so that we could become the most
successful animal on the planet
absolutely and my final question
um going back to your swarm video
so considering that the Nobel science
prize um recently was for the GPS system
in the brain So based on Swarm Shoal and
block Behavior do you believe in a human
Collective Consciousness in a sense yes
first of all I think that uh
the reason that we all know we're
conscious is because we all know that
each other is conscious and we know that
because
we we talk about it and we read novels
and you know let Martian scientists come
to Earth and suppose they aren't
conscious but they're very good
scientists I don't know if that's
possible but imagine if you can a safe
place you can build this one later one
of the things that they would have no
trouble discovering
was all the lore about human
consciousness because the movies are
full of it the books are full of it
people talk about it and so the
phenomena are there to study if there's
something that is interior and
completely outside of science
I don't know what it is I think we've
we've got the tools to study every nook
and cranny of human consciousness
whether we want to or whether we want to
sort of leave people alone and let them
stay private there's a there's a good
reason
to
keep your counsel and not reveal
everything
briefly I can't resist even I remember
there's what we call the zombie Paradox
which is this thing of somebody who uh
appears to be conscious I mean I
sometimes think this at work you know
who acts as if they were all the
evidences but in fact there's nothing
going on inside How could a martian or
you know indeed a neuroscientist to quit
with your philosophical breakthroughs
fundamentally resolve that question or
is it not is it another one of these
illusory ones yeah I think I think
that's a cognitive illusion or an
intellectual illusion of the first order
and I'm amazed that so many people are
taken in by Ireland that philosophers
take it seriously we're coming to your
place but you're nodding do you think
it's so what kind of a mistake is it to
think that that's an interesting
question it's the same it's the same
mistake that you would be making if
somebody said well you know I can
imagine a cat which is up and about and
can reproduce and eat and has a sort of
metabolism but it's not alive
well how do you know it's not alive I
don't know God told me or something
no that's just not possible you you
the act of conceiving of something is
harder than that you can't just sort of
your head and think oh yeah I can
conceive of that that doesn't count for
anything and philosophers if will he
doesn't philosophers who say oh I can
conceive of a philosophical zombie
no they can't
they just can't they can do something
but whatever it is they do is not worth
building a theory around okay I'm always
tempted to ask Nick whether that's a
fair characterization of those who who
think they've thought of one Dan says
that they have I think that's a fair
characterization of where the debate is
okay that's okay that's a nice
philosophical result I do want to check
I'm sorry if this thing of bringing
things to Consciousness so Dan's
thoughts I think in part is that it's
useful not to be aware of everything
that's going on inside your head but it
would be entirely unfeasible in fact to
get by in the world if you were you're
trying to bring more and more into
people's minds I mean is it useful not
to be aware of stuff I mean it would be
impossible to be aware of everything but
it's a little bit like your desktop
analogy so you know are you running on
iOS or Android make a choice bring the
right things to the Forefront and then
work on that basis I would say and is
that right down that we can do more
optimization so what Tara will be
claiming is that the the things which
have ended up being we're being aware of
and not by Evolution and how it's come
to be and not quite optimal we can
Tinker with it is that something you'd
be sympathetic to oh yeah I'm very very
much so I think I think that um
it's indeed very possible for people to
as or think themselves at the bad
corners and and to find themselves be
set with ideas and attitudes and fears
and so forth that are uh not just
counterproductive they're false they're
they're in a bad way and anybody who can
talk them out of it or help them out of
that is doing that person a great deal
of good and
when they're doing this they're not
doing it by Magic they're doing it by
summoning up representations in the
brains that are influential and changing
things and you don't know nobody knows
or has to know yet
where in the brain exactly it is or how
exactly the neurons are doing the
representing but we can have a good idea
of what the job of those transient
representations are what they can be
what they can do now that you're a
frequent visitor to London and these are
ideas that you've explored repeatedly
over the years but I do think that that
in 2017 in London we're in a different
place than we would have been five years
ago in one particular respect and that's
the extraordinary progress at least as
described by proponents of deep learning
machine learning the artificial
intelligence project
some of the big problems have been
cracked so chess was a blind alley
because you could just search all the
moves but go you can't search all the
moves so it has to be something right
you're wrong about Chess you could
cancel enough of them to make to make a
difference and go with sold so you know
firstly well not faster but the question
you know from you to blaze and the
Machine learning do you think we're
making real strides in the machine
learning approaching this artificial
intelligence approach towards the kinds
of things that you think are really
interesting
absolutely I do and the last chapter in
my book is about the rise of deep
learning and other techniques the new
techniques which have led to a sort of
Rebirth of AI in the last decade Jeff
Hinton and others have really had some
tremendous breakthroughs what interests
me are many things interests me about it
one of them that interests me and I
wonder if players would agree is that
all of these methods are in a certain
sense darwinian they're all they all
involve bottom-up
massive amounts of sifting and trial and
error to extract pattern from huge
databases in the same way that natural
selection has has gleaned design
information from several billion years
and millions and millions of species in
order to create the designs that we have
here so I viewed I view deep learning as
a continuation of sort of darwinian
quasi-darwinian processes now in silico
and it's tremendously successful just as
Francis Crick said evolution is cleverer
than you are